Transcriptor: Sebastian Betti
Hace unos años estaba
en el tren escuchando música
con auriculares, bailando.
Bueno, adentro me sentía así, si me veías
de afuera estaba más como...
como medio contenido, porque es un tren,
pero para el modo zombi usual
en el que viajo
me sentía Beyoncé, y en eso se me
acerca uno todo sonriente y me dice,
¿qué estás escuchando?
Hip hop, le digo, ¿querés escuchar?
Apenas se pone los auris empieza...
ojos cerrados, se mordía el labio, todo...
a distancia de cablecito de celu, o sea,
una cosa muy íntima e incomodísima para mí
--para él era muy natural-- y yo,
que hasta recién con mi bailecito
me sentía el Che Guevara del baile,
el Chayanne Guevara del tren,
tratando de salir de a poco
de mi zona de roquefort...
Y llega este... ¿zona de roque... lo qué?
Y en el silencio denso
y estático del vagón,
pudimos escuchar con los ojos
la partitura de su cuerpo,
el sonido de sus movimientos,
haciendo un conjuro
que nos despertó a todos del automático
y dejando en evidencia
que lo salvaje está siempre disponible.
Lo salvaje está siempre disponible;
¿o alguna vez viste, no sé, una chita
elongando antes de correr a una gacela
o a un grillo en una clase de canto?
Está ahí.
Y en eso me di cuenta..
del ritmo de las cosas.
Todo tiene un ritmo.
Todo lo que decimos tiene ritmo.
Todo lo que decimos tiene
ritmo... tac, tic, tac,
como si la primera inteligencia
de uno fuera rítmica.
Estás ahí, en la panza de tu vieja, como
que tu conexión con el universo
es el ritmo de tu vieja como...
Y tu primito tuk, tuk, tuk, tuk, tuk, tuk,
en la ecografía tiene ritmo.
Está vivo.
O alguien en una ambulancia.
Tomale el pulso.
No tiene ritmo.
Lo perdimos.
El ritmo, los días, las estaciones,
las ciudades tienen su tempo.
El bosque tiene otro.
Lo único medio arrítmico es la mente,
es como un nenito tocando la batería
con dos palitos...
¿pagué el gas?, ¿apagué el gas?
¿Dos y cuarto tenía dentista?
Volar, árbol...
Quedé como un boludo.
Y si bien yo no escuchaba la música
que él estaba escuchando,
claramente emanaba una música.
Yo estoy emanando una.
Vos, vos, vos.
Nos estamos contagiando unas músicas.
De hecho, siento que hay como playlist
emocionales de miles de personas a la vez.
Ponele, es feriado y...
en pantuflas, la panadería, viste, ¿doña?
¿Lindo día no? Estoy re contento.
Hora pico.
Una parejita a los besos en la plaza.
Caos de tránsito en la ciudad
de Buenos Aires.
Que para el virus del miedo
no hay barbijo ni inyecciones.
Recordemos que yo pensaba todo esto
mientras era perreado públicamente
por un desconocido,
el cual sale de su trance,
se da cuenta de que se tiene que bajar
y me dice “Gracias.
Me encanta bailar”.
¿Qué?
Eso fue todo lo que dijo gracias.
Me encanta bailar.
Corta.
Yo estaba, yo estaba prendido fuego,
imaginate ese contacto estrecho del bien,
estaba como...
¿Qué hago con todo esto?
Quería salir a desfilar por el vagón
tirando glitter, vamo arriba la vida,
estaba motivadísimo.
Re inspirado, ya con ideas
de presentar al Ministerio de Cultura
y de Salud, que son básicamente lo mismo,
Un vagón por tren,
bailable con bola de espejos.
¿Sabes cómo llega la gente al laburo?
Endorfinas arriba, las defensas.
Me tomo el de las seis
que pasa música noventosa;
(Público) Te quiero.
Yo también.
Este domingo vote.... Ideón. Y en eso
como que giro para la gente del vagón,
que hasta recién estaban
todos mirando lo que pasaba,
y veo que todos como que...
Todos volviendo a su repertorio
de movimientos conocidos...
no, no se olviden de... no, ¡Wilson!
como si hubiera caído un rayo en el vagón
y todos al toque...
Qué difícil sostener la espontaneidad;
digo, ¿qué pasa?
Porque además no es que estás tirando
una un poco rara, y alguien de la nada
va a decirte, “a ver si
podés dejar de moverte”,
“tu espontaneidad me expone”.
“Aparte, estás incomodando a los demás”.
No es que va a pasar eso.
Y si pasa, es un loco de un vagón
que no ves nunca más.
Soy yo solo el que se frena y yo solo es
un decir, porque claramente
hay unos personajes adentro de mi mente
--creo que la tuya también--
tocando botoncitos y tomando decisiones.
Y cada vez que salgo un poco de la norma,
Aleandro,
llega ella a supervisar el asunto.
Y ella es Sergia Tensini.
A ver, a ver, corazón.
¿Qué estamos haciendo? En frente de
todos, ¿te hacés el que sos de acuario?
¿Sos único, qué pasa?
¿Qué es esto?
Hola Sergia, estaba...
en unos bailes, tirando unos pasos.
¡Ah, bueno! El señorito tira
unos pasos donde se le canta.
¿No estás un poco grande para esto?
Digamos, cuando eras chico
podías jugar, ahora de grande
a lo sumo sos un hombre...
bueno, hacé ejercicio, tomá mucho.
¡No sé qué te tengo que explicar!
Hay ciertas normas.
Juancito, por favor, ¿me alcanzás el acta?
Gracias, corazón. Muy atento.
Bueno, empecemos de a poquito.
Tengo acá el acta de movimientos
permitidos en vía pública, inciso subte,
inciso tren, similares,
y tengo los movimientos...
y, bueno, tirar unos pasos...
no está, entonces está, digamos,
todo lo que es quedarse quieto,
está mirar el celu,
está somnolencia repentina ante
la presencia de una embarazada,
para no cederle el asiento.
Está todo lo que es desviarle la mirada
a un semiconocido
para charlar con él hasta Retiro.
Y baile, no está corazón.
Y este es el estatuto vigente.
Y por vigente quiero decir
que vi gente haciendo esto
y no vi gente haciendo lo tuyo
y si nadie lo hace es porque está mal.
Entonces...
Aplaudir se puede, se puede,
gracias, si está bien,
¿Está bien aplaudir en charla TED?
Sí. Perfecto.
Bueno, y si sos muy inquieto, como una
especie de ADD que no puede aguantarse,
cuando salís,
acá está permitido el running;
está el running.
Sergia, te entiendo, pero explicame esto.
[Correr] en la calle vestido de flúor
es normal y [bailar] es de loco.
O sea, no entiendo.
Me encantan tus argumentitos.
Running, running, running, running.
No, ¿me estás cargando? Más serio,
enfocado, superándose y midiendo,
posteando, Run, Forrest, run.
Eso es otra cosa, con vos no hay caso.
Bueno, ¿no te gusta el running?
OK, tenemos
algún importado de India hace poco.
Teneme Juancito, por favor.
Está permitido el saludo al sol.
Si en tu barrio no hay sol,
saludás a un edificio, un cartel, algo.
Pero esto así no puede seguir.
Sí Sergia, pero ¿viste cuando
sentís la música?
Ese diálogo interno en miles
de mentes todos los días.
Generando ruido, melodía.
Y si tenemos el cuerpo así de frenado,
imaginate las emociones, la intuición,
la espontaneidad, la intimidad,
la sensualidad, la imaginación.
Justo lo que más necesitamos
en esta mutación planetaria
en la que estamos entrando;
data nueva, fresca, real, sensible.
Me imagino miles de reuniones,
gobiernos y empresas,
señores, para aprovechar
esta crisis como oportunidad
nos vamos a sentar a hablar,
pensar y ver PowerPoints de innovación,
que seguro que así la rompemos
y decile al de la idea del tren bailable,
que es demasiada imaginación, digamos,
como que la gente alegre es peligrosa.
Entonces, vamos a seguir en el formato
de transporte de ganado humano
que es muy funcional.
Y ojo, que no digo bailar
como bailar bien, bailar mal,
ni siquiera hacer una coreografía.
Digo sentirlo, moverse y poderlo expresar.
Voy a hacer una pausa y, en el silencio,
sentir qué es lo que nos pasa.
Sentir qué es lo que nos pasa.
Y en ese silencio
es donde podemos mutar el ruido en música
y ver que lo normal, como norma,
es una pecera con vista al mar.
Comidita de “likes” para los que
no se porten mal en el zoológico virtual,
¿Para qué prestarle nuestra atención
si nunca nos la devuelven?
¿Para qué alimentar con mi carne obediente
a lo voraz,
si suficiente ya es suficiente?
Solo quiere más, más, más.
¿Y hasta cuándo?
¿Hasta mirarme en el espejo
y ser solo un viejo más?
¡Con lo fértil que es este caos!
¿Y si liberamos la insolencia creativa
de curanderes y cuentacuentos herejes
que sacan del formol a lo formal
y con la fuerza que tiñe de verde
toda la tierra después del invierno,
reencantamos al mundo con coraje,
con ternura?
El coraje de gustarnos así como somos,
de despertar la violencia
con madurez, con dulzura.
De habitar lo incómodo,
de mutar lo suave en lo feroz.
El coraje de ser un fogón en la noche,
en un desierto,
de ser una estrella que se acuerda
que es galaxia
de un hermanito diciéndole a otro:
Pedrón, fue sin querer.
O alguien bailando en un tren.
Ese día fue muy simple, escuché algo,
me conmovió, me moví.
Él me vio, se acercó.
¿Qué estás escuchando?
Escuchó.
Se movió.
Y despertó a un vagón entero, y ese
movimiento siguió meneando en el tiempo,
en este gran vagón en el que viajamos,
siguiendo las vías que deja el sol.
Y hoy lo pudiste sentir.
¿Qué vas a hacer ahora
que lo podés escuchar?
Nosotros decirte gracias.
Nos encanta bailar.